[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec des milliers
us
non
ce n'est pas tout
[Musique]
du revenu
cette page
com
[Musique]
si son miroir qui m'a permis de vaincre
la reine des neiges iphone
[Musique]
pendant
c'est fini on est tous les amateurs
on est un peu ce sens
dans le groupe c
on est bas
[Musique]
faux
je ne sais pas
[Musique]
c'est
est ce que tu as déjà fait ni bataille
s'en fait pas je vais t'apprendre
[Musique]
pourquoi pas
photo c
[Musique]
on peut transcender
c'est magnifique
je n'ai jamais rien vu de si tôt j'avais
déjà entendu parler de cet endroit
non moi non plus peut-être que personne
n'est jamais sorti vivant d'ici
[Musique]
aux dires d'un regarde la pierre aux
soins
j'arrive pas à y croire on a réussi
on l'a trouvé
[Musique]
sur pierre assouan
fait vite revenir mes parents s'il te
plaît de la siem versus
[Musique]
physiquement je sais pas du tout
du coup comme le feu
m
viendra ton esclave
toi le plus lourd avec
cette force était malade
jusque là
dès que l'étoile du nord briguera dans
les cieux l'oreille sur cette terre n'en
sera que plus glorieuses
oh
[Musique]
je sais à quel point c'est dur de ne
plus voir ses parents tu sais si je suis
passionné de légende c'est parce que je
suis moi aussi à la recherche de ma mère
disparue c'est vrai oui c'est mon voeu
le plus précieux de réussir à retrouver
un jour et je sais maintenant que ce
jour approche je sais comment la
retrouver grâce à cette légende de
trolls qui dit qu'une ans atteints
tu veux dire que omdh a raconté celle là
aussi non regarde ça on l'appelle la
pierre aux souhaits si une personne la
trouve effet un voeu il se réalisera
ça fait longtemps maintenant que je
cherche cette pierre les trolls n'ont
pas pu m'aider ils ne savent pas où
elles se cachent les grottes du sultanat
doman de la gao le temple les trolls
connaissent parfaitement cet endroit tu
sais mais personne ne peut y aller c'est
interdit un quart des oui c'est très
dangereux on risque d'être maudit ou de
se faire jeter un sort où on peut causer
des problèmes à toute la ville et même
au monde entier a nancy où ça allons
trouver cette pierre aux souhaits tu
n'es pas le seul à avoir un voeu à faire
mais tu oublies qu'on n'a pas le droit
d'y aller pour le mouillé je ferais
n'importe quoi pour ma mère
[Musique]
moi j'ai envie d'attraper
b
[Musique]
et
oh
on n'a pas l'air de s'ennuyer ici huit
cas une guerre canal fida meyer
[Musique]
à
ces filles sont toutes complètement
folle de toi tu l'as dit elles sont
folles et ça n'a rien à voir avec moi je
t'aime très fort regardez quoi pourquoi
ils nous envient tant que ça né orphelin
est on obligé de parcourir le monde
comme des gitans on est des légendes
pour ses enfants en a vaincu la reine
des neiges et sauver le monde des
légendes que sérieuse j'ai plutôt
l'impression d'être une bête de foire ou
un singe qui jouent des cymbales les
élèves seront là d'une seconde à l'autre
maintenant vous pourrez commencer dans
cinq petites minutes
ces enfants sont notre nouvelle raison
de vivre ils ont besoin de personne ne
remplacera jamais nos parents guerdat
tiens c'est pour toi pour et offrir ce
cadeau
c'est une peinture que je fait pour toi
aux cayes
c'est toi qui a fait ça merci beaucoup
elle est magnifique c'est incroyable
mais tu étais si petit la dernière fois
que tu as vu papa et maman comment tu
t'es souvenu de leur visage il m'arrive
de les voir souvent dans mon sommeil
merci beaucoup
la pierre aux souhaits ça fait longtemps
maintenant ce jeu-là fériés parker a
jamais fait ça
il nous faudra
c'est le monde tout entier qui sera
dévorée par les flammes
[Musique]
qui
c'est que commencer
on l'appelle la pierre aux souhaits si
une personne la trouve effet un voeu
il se réalisera la pierre aux souhaits
ça fait longtemps maintenant que je la
cherche
on se connaît par coeur in his ça les
esprits de la reine des neiges et du roi
du feu sont sortis de la pierre aux
souhaits et nous ont possédé rolland et
moi on n'est plus des amateurs
on est des pros ouais si on les retrouve
pas bientôt c'est le monde tout entier
qu'il sera dévorée par les flammes
ni tout
[Musique]
non
l'otan devrait peut-être attachez vos
ceintures
[Applaudissements]
il manquerait
aulas n'ont rien
nous arrêter
et comment ces jeux
e